what does it mean
to raise an animal from the beginning of
its life to the end of its life
in a way that's ethical that's humane i
think the first
piece you need to just be comfortable
with is that
making an animal into meat you know is
is something you're comfortable with
because i think that's the biggest
question right
and so certified humane actually goes
all the way through
the death of the animal how it's killed
and handled at processing
so i put that out there just to say well
that's you know this is all about
producing an animal
to die for me that's not necessarily
that's something people struggle with
with the word humane and i understand
that like i have space and empathy for
that it's a it's a complicated decision
and when you have to be comfortable with
at the outset to say this is an animal
that's going to die to feed me
yeah so we should pause on that because
i actually just uh
two days ago read a paper that argued
that
you know the killing of an animal period
cannot be humane
so it's impossible and so and that's an
argument just like you're saying
we could make but if we now on the table
kind of
take as a starting point the idea that
it's possible to kill an animal for food
in an ethical way
if we take that as a starting point so
we won't argue about that
it is worth arguing about it elsewhere
and it probably will
i will probably talk to a few vegan
folks and we'll talk about the
vegan diet i'm fascinated by it as well
so i'm torn in the whole thing
but if we just take that as a starting
point
what then is an ethical humane way to
treat an animal
i look at ethical humane animal
treatment as
the major phases of life so
conception birth and mothering
diet those are kind of the major touch
points of life
so what we're looking at
is evolutionary approach which means
is the animal eating what it evolved to
eat primarily
uh is the animal primarily outdoors
which is how all animals evolved um
given
when the climate's appropriate for it
there's certain you know times when you
can't have animals fully outdoors like
here on our ranch we um have had issues
with like
you know cold weather and things but um
so if you have if you have you know
appropriate weather conditions does the
animal outdoors um is the animal able to
nurture
and engage with its young um those are
the kind of key touch points but it's
really
the the birth let me start this one from
the scratch um
okay so when i'm looking at when i when
i consider what's humane setting aside
the death part
i look at the evolutionary diet
access to the outdoors and ideally
spending the majority of its life
outdoors
low density so animals spread out
and um engagement with young
social interactions and that's all kind
of social interaction is the cool one
i mean i also read an article that like
there that like cows for example
have social like they have friends yeah
yeah that's fascinating i mean that
piece with a young
social interaction with young social
interaction with each other
that uh at a basic level i'm sure that
interaction is not as rich as humans
but there that that piece seems to be
part of the humane picture
and you said also just a quick comment
uh
evolutionary diet meaning the diet that
they were evolved
to have and that's pretty simple you can
look at the physiology of the animal
and figure that out so ruminant species
are
lamb goats and beef and they have five
stomachs
they're they evolved eating really low
calorie
high fiber foods that's why they've got
all the stomachs they need a lot of
processing you or i were to eat grass
and die in a week right we
our physiology can't handle it cows were
built and evolved to eat this
very low calorie very high fiber very
low density food
and they walk around slowly they're
moving constantly and they're eating it
when we put them on a corn fed diet
that's the opposite of their
evolutionary diet and their systems
really struggle with it
now pigs and chickens are different pigs
and chickens are omnivores
and pigs will happily eat
chickens for example yeah our pigs on
the farm will hunt and kill rattlesnakes
and eat them um you know it it's they're
they they enjoy the they enjoy all of it
they're they're they're on me for so
that you often see and i i've seen
people try to raise like a grass-fed
chicken and that doesn't exist i mean
they need a higher omnivores
i eat everything they're what's called
monogastric they got one stomach
and that one stomach needs higher
density nutrients
so in the case of um chicken if you're
to do
you know look back in american history
in
in the 1950s it took you know commercial
chickens took like 54 weeks to come to
full weight
and now it's two and a half weeks in the
in confinement farming on our in our
systems it's like
eight ten weeks typically so it's a very
you have to give them some amount of
nutrient density
um but there's a the idea that no grain
because you that's a misinformation for
any type of commercial operation
free range regenerative pastured
everything you're going to have to have
a grain feed to get any type of it's
actually i think for
the case of chickens unless you're in a
place with like tons of natural seeds
and
grubs and worms and stuff to eat really
challenging for the chicken
so you got to give them some high
density high calorie food different from
that that's the evolutionary diet
is a really key thing that's the
fundamental thing for health
and it's also interesting because that
the evolutionary diet ties to human
health
i've looked at the nutritional analysis
on on all of our products and
it's the evolutionary diet
is for the case of beef and lamb
gets their omega three to six ratio is
the same as wild game
so it's not like beef is really
radically different from elk
a ruminant species right if you feed
beef an evolutionary diet their
nutritional profile is the same as wild
meat there's a wild room in it
you